well here's the decomposition of the of
the fundamental archetype
the dragon of chaos differentiates on
the one hand into the feminine that's
the unknown and the feminine
differentiates further into the negative
feminine than the positive feminine the
negative seven is the reason for which
hunts it's the reason for you know
there's a whole group online called men
going their own way em GTO W that's a
very interesting group to go study
there's lots of them I don't know how
many of them there are and most of them
are older many of them are men who've
been through a particularly horrifying
divorce for one reason or another and
there they've had enough of women so
they stay tell the young men that
they're teaching never have a permanent
relationship never share your territory
with the woman never share your
possessions make sure you never live
live together and don't stay with one
long enough to enter a common-law
relationship because you will be
stripped of everything that you have
well that's a hell of a thing to be
telling people but what's happened is
that the female has been manifested in
their life only as the negative
archetype and they've got that confused
with all women and that's partly you
know you've got to ask yourself if you
know the mythological story is maybe if
you made the right sacrifices you
wouldn't have so much trouble with women
it's a good question to ask yourself
first and and I would also say you know
if you're a woman who has trouble with
men or you're a man who has trouble with
women it's not the women and it's not
the man it's you because the women are
telling you what's wrong with you and
the men are telling you what's wrong
with you and if you don't listen then
it's you it's either you or all men well
that's easy it's all men well that's
certainly how it's played out in the
world right now it's like no it's not
all men you can be shown by definition
by definition and it's not all women
that's for sure I don't want to have
anything to do with women it's like
you're a pathetic weasel that's the same
statement